[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم محكمه العدل الدوليه
ترفع جلساتها للتداول بعد الاستماع لدفاع
اسرائيل في قضيه ارتكاب اباده جماعيه فريق
الدفاع الاسرائيلي طلب من المحكمه رفض
الدعوه جمله وتفصيلا في حين قال الفريق
القانوني لجنوب افريقيا ان اسرائيل اخفقت
في تقديم اي ادله لض اتهامات الاباده
الموجهه اليها وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب
غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول قصف امريكي
بريطاني لمواقع جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
في اليمن واشنطن قالت ان القصف يهدف
لتقويض قدره الجماعه على شن هجمات في
البحر الاحمر وجماعه الحوثي تقول ان كل
المصالح الامريكيه والبريطانيه اصبحت
اهدافا مشروعه الحكومه السوريه دد
الموافقه على دخول المساعدات الانسانيه
عبر معبر باب الهواء الحدودي الى مناطق لا
تسيطر عليها سته اشهر اضافيه حيث تستخدم
الامم المتحده المعبر لايصال المساعدات
الى نحو 3 ملايين شخص في الشمال غرب سوريا
بتفويض من مجلس الامن الدولي في نقطه تحول
لاكبر عمله مشفره في العالم هيئه الاوراق
الماليه الامريكيه توافق على تغيير
القواعد للسماح بانشاء صناديق تداول
بيتكوين في الولايات المتحده وهي خطوه
ستمنح المستثمرين العاديين امكانيه الوصول
الى العمله المشفره افتتاح بطوله كاس اسيا
لكره القدم في قطر بحضور امير البلاد
ورئيس الفيفا حفل افتتاح النسخه الثام ع
من البطوله اقيم في ملعب لوسيل وحمل عنوان
الفصل المفقود من كليله ودمنه وهي مجموعه
من القصص الاسيويه القديمه التي تعكس نوع
الثقافي في القاره الى
اللقاء